[Musique]
bonjour je
le parc mettre hors service des parcs il
est hors service comprend pas il est
désactivé leur service ça marche pas
qui marchent pas le pack mais marche pas
c'est un pas mais
répond plus n'ont pas retrouvé mon oui
on en parle
oui bonjour valable bonjour service
messieurs orient et ceci au niveau 2 il
faudrait que vous reculiez de environ 85
cm mais pourquoi 87 cm parce que les
capteurs sont à 87 cm voilà vous voulez
là on vous a été ramenée de résultats
pour forcément c'est trop long à la fin
le compas dans l'oeil
de quoi celui-ci là
leurs
portes ouvertes
j'aime bien quand tu me dises te plaît à
10 ans
et merci
j'ai l'augmenter pour vous maintenant
chez le maître à 2000 euros enfin ne pas
être méchant des méchants méchants
garçons prénom pèlerine s'agisse m
comment elle va celle ci alors toujours
dans la fiesta st ça va lasser bloch et
j'ai appelé la gauche c'est vrai
tous les deux comme au bon vieux temps
quoi quand on refaisait le monde à tous
les désignaient les battants pourtant
[ __ ] on a fait les 400 coups
raconte mon histoire la quantité avec
l'au-delà ton ex
avoir avancé
avance et ça va durer deux années la
personne derrière parce qu'avec sa tige
peu car les gens me sortent en juillet
enfin vous êtes en train de vous payer
ma tête là c'est pas comme ça du tout
si vous me donnez votre prénom tout un
poème
et on est et on va pas se marier la
fopac action la grand mère l'a
alors je peux prendre à tous les
français alors je verrai cape et épée au
début les à fleurs sont pas déclenchés
pour les raison simple c'est le jouet
est demandée et reculé à 80,7 senti mais
malheureusement comme la plupart des
choses qu'on lui dit salut rentre d'une
oreille ça lui sort par une autre et
vous avez craqué du cerveau
non alors le mot de passe et sa
grand-mère à trois cochons
ce peuple
souvent je sais pas peut-être bien
qu'oui peut-être percussions comme prêts
de la caisse
pourquoi faire pour les meufs
masi ski
bonjour
bonne journée
d'accord c'est bien la droite et je le
jure
sur le cac à côté
sinon alors elle peut faire autre chose
alors vous pouvez noter protéger
passe-t-il au besoin à paris je sois un
cercle
soit l'outil soit servent de centres et
de rayons
c'est par ici
si vous allez premi
prix il va partir du centre euros et qui
va arriver à la première 17 13
dans les boutons sentimental
c'est moi tout fou tout
voir et m'a dit moi je suis là depuis 8
heures du matin mental que tu sois là
depuis 8 heures du matin en venant la
barrière c'est vrai qu'on est dépendant
peu ce que vous pouvez mettre un peu de
musique devant la barrière six mois peut
aussi vous faire vraiment la barrière
s'il vous plaît mettre les mois de la
musique sérieux monsieur g j'ai envie
d'écouter de la ghana cabot oil je sais
pas d'ailleurs la main et même si
j'adore la cote l'avoir giflée que du
cas d'eric harris et booba
à ouagadougou
aïe aïe ouille et l'optimiser va pas
encore des meilleures voitures mois à ce
qui paraît ce qu'on fait mais ça m'a
embêté par elle
alors venez le voir
et on va se dire leurs quatre vérités
déjà très bon match et il a une très
bonne qualité de cheveux
mal c'est beau
bonjour et merci
une bombe atomique je peux tout cas
c'est parti
merci aux chauffards ont bien si
beaucoup
pensez vous
[Musique]
il est interdit de fumer dans le
portugal
[Musique]
voilà fort non non c'est aujourd'hui il
a donc opposé le sida monsieur justement
il ya un parking qui fonctionne il ya de
ces gars là je vois deux si bien passé
non mais ça va pas ça on le dit un soin
il entend jamais rien et estiment eux
ils croient tout permis c'est bon quoi
j'avais dit monsieur vous allez ouvrir
oui pourquoi ils crient comme celui ci
la sauce bien d'où ils sortent à l'eau
oui monsieur vous pouvez ouvrir s'il
vous plaît je ne trouve pas très aimable
moi non plus je vais pas être très mal
et je vais appeler monsieur krawczyk si
vous continuez monsieur qui foirent ku
d'origine allemande
ouvrez la
caisse a bad teacher
tristan votre cas bonjour monsieur ya
pas bonjour monsieur déjà très bien qui
je suis
comme par hasard on se retrouve
beaucoup pouvoir maintenant laisse moi
rire
ce s'il vous plaît qu'est ce que tu veux
je
suis en clientèle
c'est bon là tu comprends ça en
clientèle at raliser vrai nom maria
d'accord mais est ce qu'on peut se
parler de minutes tu penses que tu me
dokhan deux minutes vous écoute pourquoi
tu as disparu
j'ai pas le temps c'est pas le temps
c'est ma mère qui m'a tant la mise
encore faire le goût avec ta lettre tu
me la sortie 15 fois ta mère alors dans
ce cas là tu prends ma barrows à oui
mais je sais oui mais toi tu mates hors
du commun
comme toi tu as dit que tu avais rend
libre et que ta mère est à des rendez
vous avec des bd un défi de joie
c'est pas vraiment service on se pose
des questions sur la machine
qu'est ce qui vole à l'autre là tu peux
lui refermer sa tronche et à la
police
c'est pas vieux cd petitesse de qu'on
fait parce qu'aujourd'hui tu sais mais
qui ont dit dans un monde aujourd'hui la
machine s'allumant remplacer
l'accord
rejeté
dans la boulangerie pour contrer en fait
au bout d'un frère jean luc roux s'est
pas tu connais etienne chouquettes le
boulanger oui oui oui on n'a plus besoin
de toi
les chouquettes je veux les verts
moi j'y parle moins
touffait musique louis la machine et on
tue comme je suis dit écoute moi bien
mon petit gars qu'est ce qu'un
coup d'acheter pas que tu connais tu
connais jean michel beaugas il marche
lui connaît
est-ce que tu connais eric roy sans nous
avons
[Musique]
comme ça
oui des fois je me trouve à marboeuf là
j'ai un espèce de malades qu'il ouvre
pas les portes qui étaient coincées et
j'arrive pas à sortir s'il vous plaît
pas il ya un cas social qui c'est là
derrière de coos bay lui mais c'est qui
je t'aide à spa grand mère at you know
which makes ont
montré comment il parle mais on t'a
pistolet pour faire son taf ou c'est moi
je te demande juste une chose les
excuses jamais cherché tout et ça ça
j'irais sur ce magazine d'accord je vais
venir mais si je viens c'est normal et
les vents bonne saison mais je vais
venir et femmes détenus soit plus proche
il se passe quelque chose là vous pouvez
essayer de voir où il est critique
écoutez moi bien monsieur oui je vous
faire une révélation ouais je dit je
crois au chic mais vous êtes qui je ne
peux pas vous le dire mais moi je peux
pas sortir glace vous êtes gentils géo
passe chaotique allô monsieur oui fait
ce qui vous dit s'il vous plaît faites
quoi par exemple des mois de cigares et
une loi de tictacs et attention des
bigots ses joies de petits taxis 72
heures s'arracher pour ta gueule mais
c'est quoi la caisse qui se passe je le
détient l'accord qui est sous les ordres
je veux dire la machine la machine sera
toujours en dessous permis d'aller
antonio dessus ni sur deux succès comme
tu veux mais ça va
bon d'accord
tu tu fumes tu bois il se passe quoi là
ilham et tictacs
et servez hélas aucune chance j'ai
craché
dis moi que tu m'aimes
je te le dire en face ouvre la barrière
je vais venir te voir il va enfin là
comme à l'om
[ __ ] mais moi je te fais un cadeau
pour des photos de prix de tablettes
d'ici
là bonnes saveurs en fait à la plein
jour dans sa tête en
ligue 1 pas de sucre à outils
du coup le monsieur redescend quand même
invité à monter d un cran au dessus
nombre de cadeaux qui distribuent ces
bombes à
distribuer et on vous a reconnu parce
que oui ta grand mère